KARTHIK LAKSHMINARAYANAN:
Good afternoon.
Welcome to the session on
Google's identity as a service.
So I do want to begin
by thanking all of you
for showing up.
We know that you have
lots of choices in terms
of which session to attend.
Including, possibly,
taking a nap after lunch.
So thank you so
much for showing up.
My name is Karthik
Lakshminarayanan,
and I'm a PM
director on G Suite.
And I'm joined by Ameet Jani.
He's a product manager on the
Google Cloud Platform team.
And he and I will be
walking this talk together
with all of you.
And in order to show
our appreciation
for everyone who showed up, we
will have a giveaway for you.
What that is TBD.
It's going to have a little bit
of suspense through the talk.
OK.
So before we begin,
would you mind
if I could get a really quick
show of hands, how many of you
here are using Microsoft
Active Directory?
OK.
Almost everyone in the room.
Thank you.
And follow up question--
How many of you are using
some cloud identity provider?
OK pretty good.
Pretty good number of
people who are doing that.
So this really
value have probably
a well-established
identity process
when it comes to your
on premise world.
And you're living
in this dual world
of on premise, and then cloud.
You probably have a
well-established identity
process that works with
the on-prem identity.
And then you are looking to
extend that to the cloud,
hopefully using this
identity as a service.
Cloud-based identity solution.
And this is what we're
here to talk about.
The agenda here is
to just walk you
through how Google thinks
about identity as a service.
We'll walk you through
our solution in this space
and why we think
we are different.
Why should you care, right?
There are other choices,
obviously, in the market.
We'll walk you through a demo.
And we'll talk a little
bit about Go-to-Market
with partners.
And finally we'll wrap it up
with our closing takeaways.
So let's jump right in.
With identity as a service,
we think about this
as across these six categories.
The first being
directory, which is where
you have all your entities.
We think about account security.
We think about your devices,
particularly mobile.
We think about
your applications.
So the idea that your
end users can sign in
without having to
authenticate again and again.
As well as provisioning.
And I'll talk a
little bit about that.
And finally, some sort of
reporting, analytics, insights,
into what's going on
in this environment.
Now this is a
three-day conference.
You're probably going to be
seeing hundreds of slides.
So I think there
is zero probability
you're going to remember
these six categories
at the end of Friday.
And so I thought, let's
try a different approach.
Let's try to do something that--
let's walk through a life cycle.
And let's imagine that you
have 10 new employees that
are going to be starting.
They need access to a few
cloud-based applications.
They probably have
a mobile device.
So this is an audience
participation exercise, so
work with me on this.
What is it that you
think the first step you
got to do if you are an admin,
and you have 10 new employees
that are being onboarded?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: In the HR system.
KARTHIK LAKSHMINARAYANAN:
In the HR system.
Fantastic answer.
Thank you.
That is the right answer.
Of course, every answer the
audience gives is correct.
But that is absolutely the first
step that you would have to do.
There's an HR system,
maybe something
like Work Day or something
else that people are using.
And so these accounts
need to be created.
So that's where the
directory pieces come in.
Because you've got to sync this
into some [INAUDIBLE] store,
which is where the
identity pieces go in.
This is where the user comes in.
Then the next step probably--
other guesses from other people.
Its OK.
Come on.
Throw it out there.
One more.
What do you do after
the first HR system?
OK, just try to
follow the code here,
and there is an account security
piece you typically have.
Some sort of a username
password that's been generated,
like a temp password you've
got to sign in with it.
And then there are
possibly some devices.
You may have a bring
your own strategy.
You may have a
corporate-owned strategy.
What have you.
So you've got to think
about that dimension.
And then you start
thinking about what
cloud-based applications you're
going to assign or entitle
to that user.
And then you think
through that flow.
So this is typically
what you're trying to do.
The Identity Analytics
piece is really
trying to give you insights
into the usage patterns.
Maybe for a variety
of use cases.
Some of it may be
license management.
You really want to
try and understand.
You bought all these licenses.
How is that actually being used
in your organization, right?
So that's possibly one thing.
There might be interesting
login patterns and alerts
that you may want
to think about.
Maybe that's a security risk
that you want to get flagged.
So all of that falls under the
Identity Analytics umbrella.
So we think about identity
in the context of these three
platform services.
The first is the piece
that we just talked about,
which is directory.
And this is the core where you
have your users, your groups,
the devices that you
need to get registered,
and the applications that those
users or devices have access
to.
So that's the first piece.
And we believe that cloud-based
identity is an extension
of your on-premise solution.
So it's really
important that there
are tools that help you sync
from, effectively, Microsoft
Active Directory.
That's what you're using.
As most of you are.
And being able to
sync the existing
entities into the cloud
directory as well.
I think those tools
are important.
The next piece is around
access management.
So it's really about thinking
from the end user perspective.
Let's think about the
single sign-on XP.
So if you have a Windows
device, you log in.
And your machine is domain
[INAUDIBLE], what have you.
You have Windows
Integrated Auth.
You authenticate
once, and you're
able to launch these
windows applications.
But all that happens in
the cloud world, right?
And if an end user has to
have different passwords
for each application, they might
end up forgetting about it.
Or more likely-- this is
what end users do really,
really well--
which is they come up with some
easy-to-remember password that
meets the minimum
security requirements,
so that they can have to
type this again and again.
It's very easy for them to do.
Right?
And instead if
you have something
like a single sign-on solution,
you authenticate once.
You can have strong password
requirements and strong auth
requirements, and still be able
to launch these applications.
I remember there is an
employee that worked--
not for me, but with me.
And he was very proud--
our company policy.
This is pre-Google.
He was very proud
of the fact that he
had detected that the
employee policy was
you couldn't use one of
the last 10 passwords,
when you change your password.
So he had a script.
And he would effectively
change your password 10 times
and then change it back to the
same password that you had.
And he was a good
Samaritan, so he
would walk around
socializing that script,
if anybody else
wanted to use it.
So passwords end up
getting in the way.
Users are always smarter
than your password policy.
So it's really important that
we think about the access
management piece.
And there's also
policy and control.
So you might have a
sensitive payroll application
that you may not want the
user to just authenticate
with a password.
So you may have static
policies which says, hey,
if you're trying to access
this sensitive application-- it
may be an HR application,
what have you.
May need a second factor auth.
You could also have
dynamic policies in them.
Because you might have
some run time evaluation.
Like maybe an IP boundary,
or some other context
that needs to get
evaluated at run time.
All of that falls in the
access management bucket.
And last but not the least, as
people are moving to the cloud,
or at least expanding and
extending to the cloud,
we believe it's also
important to start
thinking about standards and
be very standards-driven.
When you think about
the on-premise model,
there's lots of legacy
protocols that have been there.
It creates vendor lock-in.
It creates these implementations
that become subpar over time.
So if you are a big believer
in a standards-based approach--
In fact, one of
the things I want
to talk about from a
[? pain ?] standpoint
is this bucket on the top,
which is provisioning.
It is overloaded
term in itself a bit.
In this context, it's
about admin provisioning.
So when you think about
admin and the number of users
that they have to
manage and the access
of different applications
for those users.
So this starts to
become unwieldy,
because if you have half a
dozen to a dozen applications--
cloud-based applications.
And you have to now
manage different users
in each of these
applications, it becomes hard
if you have to go do that.
So as an example,
John has access
in Work Day, In Sevice Now,
G Suite, Box, what have you.
And you keep managing that,
it becomes pretty hard.
We think a good identity
solution can centralize that.
So you have that one place.
And the identity
vendor can actively
manage the right user access
within those applications.
All driven by standards
like [? SKIM, ?] which
is specifically used
for the provision.
OK, so that's sort of our
view of identity as a service.
And we're very serious
about this thing.
And we realize as we've extended
and grown beyond G Suite--
I think G Suite was like the
first major offering that
was targeted at businesses
and enterprises.
And we realized that
there are customers
who are now onboarding
other Google services, GCP
services that they're building.
Android Chrome, what have you.
And we are announcing
a standalone identity
as a service solution.
We are branding it
as Cloud Identity.
This is something that's
in development right now.
And we will have a bit
of this next quarter.
The key here is
that we really want
to make this super easy
for organizations as they
onboard onto Google services.
To onboard those
enterprise identity,
using our identity as
a service solution.
So again, the brand
is cloud identity.
It's in development, and we'll
have a beta next quarter.
Here's the interesting part.
How many of you here
are G Suite users?
Again a quick show
of hands please.
Very nice.
Thank you so much.
We appreciate you
being a G Suite user.
But here's the hidden
secret in all of this.
Our Cloud Identity
solution is already a part
of that G Suite solution.
So many of you,
if not all of you,
have been using our identity
solution to provision
and manage the variety
of applications that are
included as part of G Suite.
So the key thing that
we are doing here
is taking that identity
that was part of G Suite--
so had to be a G Suite customer.
And as people are
coming on and saying,
hey, I'm trying to build
these GCP services.
I'm maybe not a G Suite
user, then what do I do?
I want to use your identity.
So what we're doing
is pulling that out.
It's almost like this
best-kept secret.
Shouldn't have been a secret.
We are pulling that
out and making that
a standalone identity
as a service solution.
Which we are calling
Cloud Identity.
So here's the key thing.
This is not something that's
new that we are really
using in beta.
This is something
that's been used
by millions of
business customers
already as part of G Suite.
So we are just unpacking it
a little bit, so you do not
have to be a G Suite user.
So going back, as we think
about enterprise identities,
And we think about these
enterprise services
that we bring to market that
are cloud identity offering,
you can now onboard those
identities as a first step.
We know that identity is now
becoming front and center.
[INAUDIBLE] the
heart and soul all
of these additional
services that are
being used in an organization.
So the idea is you onboard once.
You might onboard--
maybe not with G Suite.
You onboard maybe with a GCP
service you are building.
Maybe you're building an
application using our machine
learning services that
you want to roll out
for the subset of
your employees.
So you can do that with
Google Cloud Identity.
And then at some
point in the future,
you may want to try
out something else.
You may want to try out Google
Drive for your organization.
It's the same identity solution.
You don't need to roll
out something new.
And it's all managed
through one admin control.
So it's really easy to layer on
and add on additional services.
OK, I hope that's appealing.
Here's the other piece
around Google Cloud.
How many of you here are
existing GCP customers?
OK, good size.
And evaluating GCP?
Maybe?
OK.
So when you think about our
GCP services and Google Cloud
Identity again-- in
fact, we'll walk you
through a demo of this.
It's very easy for you to think
about this as a service aspect.
So GCP already has a
variety of services for you.
You can now onboard and
sign up for cloud identity
as another service, and it's
completely driven by being
self-service and online.
The challenge for
those of you who
are Google Cloud customers
is when to date--
if you want enterprise identity,
it's an offline process.
In the sense you typically
have to call a sales
rep on the Google side, and
then they put in a request.
We have to do some provisioning
magic at the back end.
And then you get identity as
a service in your cloud admin
console.
You no longer will
have to do that.
And we'll show
that demo shortly.
One last piece as we think about
Google and Google identity.
Our Cloud Identity solution
also works beyond G Suite.
So we do have use cases
when, even today, customers
are not always using G Suite.
Or definitely not for all the
employees in an organization.
A classic example, we
have this large customer.
They have a lot of
retail floor workers.
So these are employees who
are using mobile devices.
They have access to these
inventory applications built
on the cloud, but
not using G Suite.
And they need access to
these inventory applications.
And so they can
use Cloud Identity.
So even though a subset of those
users are not using G Suite--
others are--
they use Cloud Identity in order
to manage other applications.
Even if they're not G Suite.
So that's the idea.
We have out-of-the-box support
for things like single sign-on
for a variety of applications.
This is a small sample here.
OK.
That is identity as a service.
That's Google's
identity as a service.
And many of you
raised your hands
and said you're already looking
at a cloud-based identity
provider.
So why worry about Google?
Or why should you care?
What's unique about what Google
has to offer in the space?
The key here is one word.
If you can remember
that one thing, is we
are really, really
proud of our security.
You heard this in Diane's
keynote earlier today.
And something that we take a lot
of pride in is around security.
So let's understand why.
Right?
Let's start with the very
first thing about our services.
We have seven
services that actually
have a monthly active user
count of a billion users.
OK.
And I'll give you the first two.
It's YouTube and Search.
Anyone want to volunteer
the other names?
What else has a monthly active
user count of a billion users?
AUDIENCE: Apps.
KARTHIK LAKSHMINARAYANAN: Apps.
OK.
Not all of apps.
AUDIENCE: Maps.
KARTHIK LAKSHMINARAYANAN: Maps.
Yes.
Maps.
Correct.
That's true.
Others?
AUDIENCE: Gmail.
KARTHIK LAKSHMINARAYANAN: Gmail.
That's correct.
That's four.
Other two.
Maps and Gmail.
AUDIENCE: Hangout.
KARTHIK LAKSHMINARAYANAN:
Hangout.
Not yet.
We hope to get there.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Google Docs.
KARTHIK LAKSHMINARAYANAN:
Google Docs.
Not yet.
We'll get there.
Drive.
Also not there.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Chrome.
KARTHIK LAKSHMINARAYANAN:
Chrome, yes.
That is correct.
Chrome is the first one.
So YouTube, Search,
Maps, Chrome, Gmail.
AUDIENCE: Play.
KARTHIK LAKSHMINARAYANAN: Play.
Number six.
One more.
Probably you carry
phones that run this.
Android, thank you.
That's seven.
So what happens when you
run these seven services--
the more important
thing here is that we
have sophisticated systems.
These have all been
custom-built by us.
And there are additional
talks on security
throughout the conference.
So we build these
custom-hardened systems
that go all the way from
the hardware to the network
to the software that
runs on it in order
to ensure that they have
the right level of security
and control.
The other pieces that
come with it is we
use machine-learning and
other sophisticated techniques
to detect things like attacks.
Spoofing attacks.
Things like that.
To keep this data really safe.
And it's the same security.
The same infrastructure.
The same technology
that we are using that
powers our cloud
identity as well.
Here is the other key part
of it, which is reliability.
So our business-- the money that
Google makes on an annual basis
also runs on this.
So if you can't, on
the consumer side,
let's say log in and have
an Ads account that you're
managing for your organization.
That has a significant
impact to Google's business.
So we go a long way to ensure
that this infrastructure is
up and running.
And protected against all
kinds of attacks and threats.
So when you move your data--
those crown jewels that is now
sitting in an
on-premise directory--
and you extend that to
Google Cloud Identity,
this is what's going to happen.
The same security that we
use to protect our business
is now going to go to work
protecting your business.
So our security
becomes your security
when you move to our
cloud identity solution.
Let's talk about one
more thing, which
is around account security.
How many of you here are using
some form of second factor
auth in your organization?
Anyone not using
second factor auth?
OK.
I think everyone's probably
moved on from not just having
a password-based control.
And when we think about
one-time-use passwords,
the most common ones end
up being some sort of phone
that people are using to
get this one-time-use key.
Do you see a few different
problems that come up with it?
The first being that--
and probably the most important
one is being around cost.
Because when you enable a
second factor auth solution that
focuses on a mobile
phone, the employee
is asking the organization
to pay for that bill.
And that increases the costs.
If you forget your
phone or what have you,
then you now have
this weird thing
of how do I log in, et cetera.
So there's a problem with that.
There are other issues, like
SMS connectivity and so on.
But probably from a
usability standpoint,
the thing that
happens is every time
you go to type in this
key-- whether it's
from a VPN-based,
one of those keys,
or whether it is from
your one-time password.
And Verizon had this really
interesting data point,
where they did this survey.
And they found that--
I think it was about 75%, 79%.
Something like that.
A really high number.
That the attacks actually
happened because existing
accounts-- the
existing employees,
their accounts get compromised.
And then that's how they get in.
So it's not really
some hacker who's
able to break through
into your system,
it's an employee
that gets phished,
and then it's that employee's
account masquerading around,
causing all kind of
havoc in your system.
So there's a
fundamental problem,
because when you
get a key that's
valid for one, five minutes,
that key can be read.
It's human-readable,
and it can be phished.
So that's a key problem.
So something that
Google worked on--
working with the FIDO Alliance.
And again, contributing
back to that open standards
and open source
community is this thing
which you call security keys.
And it's something
that you may have
heard of if you are a G
Suite enterprise customer.
It's included in that.
But these security
keys are interesting.
All of you are going
to get one of these
when you walk out today.
This is something that
has a couple of ways
you put it into a USB key.
Like those two keys on
the left and the right.
And then the one in the middle
is a Bluetooth low energy
enabled key, so it works
with your phone as well.
Here's a key
difference, OK, which
is it's an encrypted signal.
So even if you are phished.
Instead of going
to Google dot com,
you went to goggle dot com.
And you are typing
your password in.
Even if somebody
gets that password,
your signal is
completely encrypted.
So the second factor--
So that person who
phished you is not
going to do much with that key.
Because Google is going to look
for, not just the password,
but the whole second key that's
sent through an encrypted
signal.
And that token is not
going to be valid.
And this auth attempt
is going to be declined.
In fact, interesting story--
that I have been at Google,
and I have never changed
my actual password.
And I swear to god, on my
first day I had to change it,
based on the temp
password I got.
I've never changed my password.
I do not VPN in from anywhere.
I can work from a
kiosk like this.
And I'm a director at
Google, so I get access
to a fair amount
of sensitive data.
Employee data, perf
data, things like that.
And I'm not asked to
change my password,
because every time I log
in I have the security key.
So Google runs our
business on this security,
and these keys are
now available for you.
Each and every one of you is
going to get one of these keys
when you walk out later today.
Please do try it out.
If you like the experience,
continue rolling this out more
broadly in your organization.
[INAUDIBLE] account security.
One more thing is that
these keys are available.
You can buy them on
Amazon or what have you.
And I'm going to
put this up here.
And we'll try to figure it
out if you can keep this
up a little bit later.
But there's a coupon code.
You get 40% to 50% off
depending on which key code--
which one you actually go for.
I think the one on
the top is 40% off.
The one below 50%.
So please do take a look.
There's a coupon there,
and do try it out.
OK, that's what we
think we are better at.
And this is why we think
you should consider us
for your cloud
identity solutions.
So with that,
we're going to dive
into how Cloud Identity is
going to help with your GCP
onboarding use-cases.
So for that, I'm going to
please invite again Ameet Jani,
and he's going to walk
you through this section.
Welcom Ameet.
AMEET JANI: Thank you, Karthik.
Hi, everybody, I'm Ameet.
I'm a product manager on
the Google Cloud side.
And I saw some hands go up when
Karthik asked how many of you
are on Google Cloud.
Let me ask a more detailed
question-- how many of you
suffered through our
onboarding process
to get your enterprise on board?
All right, well, then
I've got great news we
should be excited about today.
At least I'm excited
about it, because I'll
stop getting angry phone calls.
This is the idea that
we're now putting
identity front and center in
your sign up process, right?
As you go onboard--
let me walk you through a
typical customer journey.
I come in, I'm a customer.
I'm using my Gmail account
to test out Google Cloud.
I like what I see.
I love it, in fact.
And I want to start moving
my enterprise there.
I can now, instead of
this tedious process
of some backend phone call--
I can write front and center.
Start the click and onboard
my enterprise, as it were.
I can start with my DevOps.
I can include the security
operations people.
And eventually I can bring
my entire enterprise onboard,
without any long delay and
process and manual provisioning
thing that needs to occur.
So I'm going to
walk through a demo.
Before I do, I think as
a Google Cloud customer
you'll find that
Identity is really
the pivot point around which
you make your access management
decisions.
There's no surprise there.
It is for those of you who are
familiar with our cloud IAM
story.
It is the I in IAM, right?
Who are the security principals?
Who are the users and
groups that I'm allowing?
And what are the access that
I'm going to give those people?
You have rich policies
on prem today, right?
You have workflows and users.
And you've taken the time
to assign users to groups,
and then assign those
groups to roles so
that you can control access.
You just want to naturally
extend that into the cloud,
and that is exactly
the direction we
are moving to with all of this.
Just before I jump
to the demo, we
do this in a very
simplified way.
We talk about who, right?
You have these users and
some on-premise system.
Now with this IDaaS,
you can now synchronize
everybody or federate
everybody to Google Cloud.
You can start to
assign them roles.
Roles are just obviously a
collection of permissions.
So let's walk through
an actual example.
I'm a network administrator.
I want to be able to
configure firewalls.
I am part of the network
administrator group.
You just assign that
custom role to those users
or to that group, and
there's a double icon there.
But you get the
sense that now you
can control access
to the VMs that
can access the firewalls
that they can set up.
Or other cloud resources.
You can even start to use
the same identities in groups
and roles to control access to
the applications themselves.
I've lifted and shifted an
SAP system to the cloud.
I can now say, if you're a
member of the finance group you
should have access,
otherwise you shouldn't.
Those are the rich
things you can
start to do as you move
out to the Identity system.
If we could switch computers,
I wanted to run through--
can you guys see my screen?
If you could see
it, you'd be amazed.
So I was going to do this
live, and then all week I
was getting this passive
aggressive comment
from my boss.
He's like, oh, you're
going to do live
on a conference wireless.
So I chickened out at the
end and I recorded it.
It is real, but
it's recorded here.
So this is my actual browser.
You'll see I'm going
to log into Pantheon.
Excuse me, Cloud Console.
I log into Cloud Console here.
You'll see it says,
this is Ameet at Gmail.
I'm here, I'm going
to go play with my--
I love what I see here.
I go to IM and Admin.
The first thing you'll see is--
and this is actually the
exciting part-- front
and center identity starts
to show up there, right?
No more figuring out what that
means and what's going on.
We try to make it
very easy to say,
A-- you can sign
up for identity.
B-- if you don't
know what identity is
or what it means--
you missed this talk--
you can find out
the documentation.
Or you can go jump right
into user management
if you've already
done all this, right?
The second thing I
want to point out,
for those of you who walk
their identity onboarding flow,
I'm now in my sign up flow.
I'm going to walk
this in five minutes.
Of course, I was going to walk
through it in five minutes.
You'll notice-- there it is--
that it's branded Google clouds.
As Karthik was saying, this
is the same identities system
for everybody.
For all Google properties.
But we're trying to make this
a very native journey for those
of you who are in cloud, right?
You're in cloud.
You're used to seeing
what you see here.
Or not seeing I guess.
All the stuff that's here.
Why don't I go
through it quickly,
so we don't lose it again.
You're going through
the sign up flow here.
I'm signing up myself
as my user identity.
In this example, I have my
domain called Zott Kicks.
I sign up Zott Kicks.
I just need to verify
that I own that domain.
So this is the domain
I'm going to be using.
I'm using a subdomain
as this example.
And then per best practice--
I'm going to pause here because
you missed the beginning part--
I'm signing up a group
of administrators
to gain access to
all this, right?
I'm creating some
temporary password.
And then I'm going to walk
through and verify who I am.
There's a robot sign
that goes on here.
You're enhancing the Google
machine learning algorithm,
by doing all this.
I don't want any of the
spam that comes with it.
I agree to the terms.
The terms basically say I
can send you spam email.
And then you're off
to the races, right?
You're signing up
for this new account.
So the next thing in the list--
now you've done step one here.
I'll pause it for a second.
You can see you set
up the cloud identity.
You'll notice the branding
is still a cloud identity.
So you're not confused and
lost in this G Suite and Google
Cloud world.
So now the second part of
this three-step process
is I need to verify that,
in fact, my corporation owns
this domain.
So nobody should be
able to come and claim
that you own that domain
if they don't, right?
So I've done the first step.
I'm going to jump into the
domain verification step.
There's a couple of things
I want to point out here
in all of this.
First is-- and I walked
through an example here.
There are two or three
ways to verify your domain.
The first one is you can add
a tag to your main html page.
Most of you don't
want to do that.
I'm going to walk through, in
this demo, the example of how
most of our customers do it.
I'm just going to
edit the DNS registry.
So here I come in.
You see that I can add a text--
a value to a text
record in my DNS
to prove that I own the domain.
So here's an example, right?
I'm going to do
it for Zott Kicks.
For this subdomain, this
is a text value, right?
I'm able to just copy it, and
then jump into my DNS registry.
So here is what I'm
doing in the demo here.
Jumping into my DNS registry.
I want to pause
here for a second.
Because this is Google,
I'm using Google Domains.
You can use any of the
domain providers you have.
I'm not in my DNS
configuration setting, which
is the middle one there, right?
So I'm not going to go
and validate that I do,
in fact, own Zott
Kicks to Google.
So I'm going to scroll down
to, not registered host,
but I'm going to come down
to my Custom resource.
This is my subdomain.
I'm going to select
the text value.
The txt value.
It's a simple copy and paste.
And then we're off
to the races, right?
So now you're seeing this
updates to DNS within a minute.
So now that I've done
that, I can come in here
and say, yes, I've done
what you wanted me to do.
I set up the DNS, set up the
text value verification record.
Verified the domain.
The sign up process
goes through and makes
sure that you, in fact,
did update the domain.
That you are who
you say you are.
And congratulations,
you are now onboarded.
Your enterprise
is now onboarded.
Now, I'm going to
walk through a flow
here where I'm going to go ahead
and create a secondary user.
We call it the hit
by the bus problem.
If the admin gets hit
by a bus, anybody else
should not be locked
out from there.
But there are multiple ways to
synchronize your identities.
Many of you have hundreds,
if not thousands, if not
hundreds of thousands of
users that will need access
to these resources.
And you don't want to manually
add them this way, right?
So we have these sync
tools and federated
tools where you can synchronize
your on-prem identity
to the cloud.
But in this example,
I'm creating
just a backup of somebody
else who can access.
So in this case, Ford
Prefect can log in.
I send him a little
standard form email.
So I don't have
his email address.
He'll have the new
username and password.
Next.
OK, so I'm set up.
And now I've created
somebody else who can access.
And now I want to log in as
that domain user that I had.
No more ameet@gmail.
I want to be
ameet@zottkitcks.com.
I'm automatically
logged in here.
So you see, I clicked on it.
And now I'm in a
domain-controlled Google Cloud
environment, right?
This is company-owned.
I need to set up
for company billing.
No more rogue projects.
No more trying to figure out
what's out there in my name.
It's all controlled here simply.
And now, this is where
I conclude the demo.
But this is, in
essence, where we say,
now you can start
creating projects
and set up your billing account
and set up all your roles.
So I'm going to stop there.
And I'm going to hand
it back to Karthik.
But that's, in essence, the
power of the identity stuff
that we're introducing.
You don't have to be a
G Suite user anymore.
Now you're just a
Google Cloud user.
And you can still walk
through the same flow
that everybody else does.
All right.
Thanks, Karthik.
[APPLAUSE]
KARTHIK LAKSHMINARAYANAN: Great.
Thank you so much, Ameet.
I hope that was helpful.
And I hope that
showed how easy it
is to just sign up for
Identity as a Service
for your organization.
And it's something, again, it's
in beta early next quarter.
And we hope that
you like using it.
And this is not tied to G
Suite or anything like that.
You can just sign up for
Google's Cloud Identity.
So let's talk a little
bit about go to markets.
Recall, again, from a demo
and from an agenda standpoint,
we wanted to talk about, what
is Identity as a Service?
What's Google's
solution in this space?
We talked about our
differentiators,
which is security.
And now we want to talk about
how you think about this
from a go-to-market standpoint.
Because like we were
saying at the beginning,
there is an on-premise world.
And this is that well-managed,
well-oiled machine
that you're running.
Now you're extending it
and bringing cloud identity
into your organization.
So as you start to do that,
it's important to think
about these hybrid use cases.
And what Google
does is we support
these web standards and
[? modern ?] standards
on SAML and OAuth and OIDC.
What we don't have
out of the box
is support for these legacy
or identity 1.0 protocols,
like Kerberos and WS Fed.
But this is where we
have partnered closely.
We have these two
partners, Ping and Okta.
And we have them as part of our
recommended for work program.
And the idea being that you use
these partners as an ID bridge.
So the idea being we
could authenticate,
treat Ping and Okta as an app.
And that, in turn, takes
care of your existing cloud
on-premise use cases.
So we can do the cloud use cases
and the existing on-premise use
cases.
You can partner with somebody
like a Ping and Okta.
And we have a great
relationship with them.
So very quickly,
why consider this?
Because really, it's a get
the best of both worlds
kind of scenario, right?
We think that if you believe in
our value prop and our promise
that our security
is going to do more
to protect your
directory in the cloud,
then please go with
us as that cloud
identity as your directory.
And use that to
protect your crown
jewels for those
cloud-based use cases.
And use the partners
as an ID bridge
in order to address some of
your more complex use cases
and some of your
hybrid use cases.
Don't just take my word for it.
We actually have an
additional speaker
that we didn't use upfront.
And this is from Netflix.
And it's my pleasure to
introduce Tejas Dharamshi.
He is a senior security
software engineer.
He works on Netflix
cloud security.
So please learn more about--
please share more with
us about how you're
using Google Cloud Identity.
And I think it's
fascinating to see
how a forward-thinking
customer is using us to serve
their mission critical needs.
But to hear more about
it, please welcome Tejas.
TEJAS DHARAMSHI: Thank you.
KARTHIK LAKSHMINARAYANAN:
Thank you, Tejas.
TEJAS DHARAMSHI: So, yes.
Before we get into learning what
identity and how Netflix deals
with identity, let's
first understand
what it means to be in
a Netflix ecosystem.
So we have apps,
studios apps, basically,
which manage the entire
life cycle of a production,
from an inception to PR to
marketing to localization
to encoding [INAUDIBLE].
So entire end-to-end
workflow, we
have a suite of
applications to do that.
Then we have engineering
applications,
which manage the
entire deployment
pipeline to our
big data platform
to the two other
developer tools.
So a whole bunch of
engineering apps.
And we have corporate
applications.
So we're talking about more
than 500 such applications.
So in such varied apps,
what you don't want
is everyone going and
building their own identity
directory and managing
authentication, session
management, and other aspects.
It's a huge risk, especially
for a firm like Netflix.
So we definitely
don't want to do this.
What we want is a single
identity directory.
This is where Cloud Identity
offering from Google
comes into picture.
And at the same time, don't
confuse people, right?
Don't confuse with
varied login experience.
Just a single login experience.
That's another key aspect.
And also, we don't want
everyone to just keep
logging in all the time to
access so many applications.
We want single sign-on.
And the last piece, which is
key to us, is adaptive security.
How can we extend
the security model
and add Netflix juice
in there, right?
So adaptive security
is another key aspect.
So this leads to the
birth of Netflix identity.
We call it Meechum.
I hope everyone is aware
of the character Meechum
from "House of Cards."
So that's where the
name comes from.
So the heart to our identity
is our infrastructure.
So we have a highly scalable,
active/active, multi-region
infrastructure on AWS.
That's where our identity
infrastructure runs off.
As Karthik was mentioning,
and on the slides,
we use Google as the
identity directory
as well as our provider,
and we use Ping as a broker.
Ping actually helps us
add that last piece,
which we're talking about, as
the custom adaptive security
that we're talking about, right?
So I'm going to go more
in detail about that.
But these are the core aspects
about Netflix identity.
So the Cloud Identity
offering from Google,
it provide some key aspects.
A, custom user schema.
So based on your
organization requirements,
you can define your
own custom schema
and mark attributes
that are public,
which means that anyone can
access, or admin attributes.
In this particular
case, I'm talking
about the hire date
or employee type
or any other
sensitive information.
And the second thing
that it actually helps us
is automate the entire
user life cycle.
So [INAUDIBLE] gives you
APIs to actually do that.
So in our case, user
gets created in Workday,
gets synced to the ID
identity directory, and even
the deprovisioning aspect.
Next aspect is groups.
So the way we treat
groups at Netflix
is like, we use groups as a way
of [INAUDIBLE] applications.
Either developers
use groups as a way
to [INAUDIBLE] in their
application or admin
created groups to [INAUDIBLE]
very sensitive applications.
Another aspect that the Cloud
Identity offering provides us
is basically the support
of isolation, right?
So you can isolate people and
groups in their own domains.
You can create subdomains.
But the way we want
it to go about that
is to have their own
distinct domains.
So in our case, we have
employees in their own domain.
Contractors, customer
service, DBD,
everyone in their own domains.
And the OpenID Connect
User info endpoint
can be customized now, right?
So you can create your
own user information
that you want to expose
as part of the OpenID
Connect [INAUDIBLE].
So let's take the classic
example of an OpenID Connect
authentication workflow.
A user goes through one of
these engineering applications.
They don't have a
valid Meechum session,
they get redirected to Meechum.
Further down, there's
no valid Google session,
gets redirected to Google.
And that's where the unified
login experience comes
into picture, right?
In addition to that, based
on risk analysis carried out
by Google, you might be
presented by the second factor.
On everything successful, an
access token and an ID token
gets generated.
Classic authentication cycle.
And that's the first piece.
Unsuccessful authentication,
ask and query user information.
And do [INAUDIBLE] around
that or do some custom stuff
around that, right?
So do sample user,
info, endpoint,
exposing public attributes
as well as the groups
that I'm part of.
So now this helps us
check three boxes, right?
So now we have Google or
the Cloud Identity offering
being the central ID or
the identity directory.
We have unified
login experience.
And we have added
single sign-on.
So does that mean
that we call it a day
and we are happy with that?
How can we take this
to the next step?
And this is where the
adaptive authentication
comes into picture.
So me as a user, can I
access pretty much any app
that we have in a
suite of applications?
Probably not a good idea, right?
So that's where
adaptive authentication
comes into picture.
And the key factors to that
are role-based access control,
what sort of a pattern,
access pattern,
me as a user has for
these [INAUDIBLE]
set of applications, and
finally, anomaly detection.
I'm going to dive into each
of these aspects in a bit.
But these are the
core constructs
around our adaptive
authentication.
So the first one is
role-based access control.
So now we have every user
in their own Google domain.
We have users and
we have groups.
And remember, user meaning they
had their own custom schema.
So how can we leverage that?
So these attributes
are available.
And they are available
to every developer who is
building an app within Netflix.
And we believe in freedom
and responsibility.
So these attributes
are available to them.
And they use self-service
tools to go and say
that oh, I want to
enable all Netflix
employees for my
application or contractors.
And further down, I can say that
which groups and users I want
to allow access to.
The next step to this is,
also, can we use a schema
and say that, hey, everyone in
this organization has access?
So that I don't have to worry
about new people joining
or people leaving.
Everyone will have access.
So that's the first step.
The next step is
access pattern, right?
So we have users now who
have access based on roles.
But my account
can be compromised
or my device gets stolen.
There can be varied scenarios.
So we need to figure
out what is normal
and what is not normal from
a user's perspective, right?
So [? page ?] [? is ?] accessing
an engineering application
versus [? page is ?] all of
a sudden going to a financial
application or to a production
suite of applications.
What is normal?
So from Meechum,
all this information
gets streamed and logging
into our centralized logging
infrastructure.
From there, data aggregation
happens and a user profile
is built. So user
profile meaning
from where the
user is accessing,
which app user is accessing.
When is he accessing?
At what frequency is the user
accessing the application?
So based on that, a user
profile is basically built.
Now we have the profile,
how do we define policies?
Again, we have
self-service tools
to create a policy for
every app, for every user,
and define a whole bunch
of metrics around that.
So now we have policy and
we have a user profile.
How can we gel these
two things together
during the authentication?
So in Meechum, we
have another adapter
that kicks in, which is an
access pattern adapter, which
takes a peek into these
user profile and policies.
And if something
unusual is detected,
a second factor is sent to
the end user using [? dual. ?]
And only after confirmation
is a user allowed access.
So this is where, in addition
to Google's second factor, based
on our risk analysis, we send
out a second factor to the end
user using [? dual ?] security.
And the last piece
being anomaly detection.
Again, from the
information that is getting
logged into our
logging structure,
we figure out whether
things are normal
or there's any anomaly
in your access pattern.
Maybe you are trying to access
the same app at the same time
from multiple devices.
Is that really normal?
May not be, right?
So in that case, an email
is sent out to the end user.
Only after confirmation
on that email
will the access be
granted to that end user.
So this is what is
Netflix identity
and, in general,
adaptive authentication.
And now we have all
four checkboxes checked.
So this is what it means.
So just to summarize
the four pillars,
AWS is where our
entire infrastructure
is, Google being the primary
identity directory as well
as our provider.
And Ping being our ID
broker, which helps us
get to adaptive authentication.
Thank you.
Thanks, Karthik.
KARTHIK LAKSHMINARAYANAN:
Thank you so much.
We thought it'll be helpful to
just forget all the marketing
and talk high level.
We thought it'd be
helpful to just walk you
through an actual customer,
how they're using us
as part of their
critical infrastructure
and as part of
their productivity
in day-to-day business.
I think the other piece,
just to quickly reiterate,
I think Netflix has been
a great G Suite customer.
And that's how they've been
able to run Cloud Identity.
And just to reiterate,
now we'll have
this as a standalone service.
That will be the beta
that'll go out next quarter.
So thanks again.
We hope that that was useful.
So we are close to the end.
We talked about our
identity solution.
differentiators.
We talked about how we could
go to market with partners.
And then the Netflix case study.
One thing I do want to bring up,
it's near and dear to my heart.
As I talk to customers
and as I talk to people,
the question that always
comes up is people do
think Google's tech
is pretty good.
That's not the issue.
People do worry about,
what does it mean when
my stuff is running on Google?
And they always
worry, whether it
is because of [INAUDIBLE]
created by the competition
or whether it's real
concerns, we acknowledge
that perception is reality.
The fact that they worry,
is this data something
that Google is now going
to mine, start showing ads
around it?
Absolutely not the case, right?
Please do read our
terms of service.
Our terms of service
for enterprise use cases
is different.
And we have different
thoughts for consumer.
Your data is your data, right?
We are not here
to show ads on it.
So please, that is not the case.
Please read terms of service and
you'll see exactly how we plan
or how we use the data or not.
So that's the first thing.
No ads.
If you had to
remember one thing,
no, we don't use it for ads, OK?
So that's one.
The second is about compliance
and regulatory needs.
So we recognize that
most of you here probably
have instances and employees
all around the world.
Laws are different in
different countries.
And you have to meet
those local laws.
So we work very, very hard.
And we have a ton
of certifications
to show that we are complying
with all laws, all local laws,
wherever you may be operating.
So that's the second
piece about compliance
and regulatory needs.
And then the third
piece that comes up,
which is there's
always technology,
but we've also perfected and we
continue to be extremely open--
there's actually a link that--
I know you can't see it,
but I'm happy to share that
after the talk.
But we are publicly
documenting everything
that we do, not just
from a tech standpoint,
but also from a
process standpoint.
Like I mentioned
previously, our data centers
are custom-built all the
way from the hardware
to the network to the software.
And they're hardened
systems, right?
But more importantly,
what happens to employees?
And what are the access policies
for a Google employee that's
working in our data center?
So it's publicly documented.
We have background checks.
We have independent audits.
So please do go
through that as well.
If you're interested, everything
is available on our website.
So it's really
important that we think,
not just from a tech standpoint,
but also from a process
standpoint, we think this
is a pretty hardened system.
And I really cannot go in and
just start looking for data.
That is, everything is logged.
I would actually
get permission, I
would have justification,
all those kinds of things.
And I actually can't
access data just
because I'm a Google employee.
So please do read up on that.
Anytime somebody says
something to the effect
that we are using your data for
other reasons, needs to realize
that is not the case.
And please do check up on
where we are at online.
I'm happy to have a
conversation offline as well.
So this is my last slide.
And we think about
Google's IDaaS solution,
at least we think that
we can bring our security
to run your
business-critical cases.
So now our security is at
work becoming your security.
That's the key thing.
Second, you saw this,
which is everything we do
is open and standards-based.
In fact, the enterprise
security keys
that we talked about, we worked
together with the FIDO Alliance
and we helped create
that standard.
And that's the standard
that anybody is
open to using and implementing.
So we're not here to keep
our innovation to ourselves.
But we want to contribute
back for the greater
good of the community.
The third is, you saw
Ameet's demo, which
is 100% self-service.
So those of you who
are in the audience
that have been using our
Google Cloud Platform
and you've had
to, unfortunately,
live with some of the
pain of an offline
sign up and offline
provisioning mainly
taking days before you
can be up and running,
we now have a 100% self-service.
And it is not tied
to G Suite, right?
You can use it for your other
G Suite users if you want.
That was a problem as well.
So now you can do that.
You can use it for GCP.
And this'll just extend,
because it is the same identity
if you're thinking of
Chromebooks or other Google
services.
So that's number three.
And the fourth is, your
trust is important to us.
So we do a variety of things,
including meeting local laws,
but also making sure that we are
very transparent about our data
access policies
and what have you,
so you understand how we
treat your data if you do move
to Google Cloud Identity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]